So this is a sample of iridium, now this is
a sponge-type
iridium so it is very finely divided, very,
very light weight. So,
we open the vial.
Iridium is at the bottom of the group that
has cobalt and
rhodium, and iridium, like rhodium, can be
used in a lot of
catalysts.
And here we have the glass ampule inside and
we can see
here that the iridium sample is a sponge.
Now again you can
see that this is a very, very, very light
material and you can
see it flowing inside the vial.
In fact, iridium catalysts sometimes will
work much better
than the rhodium catalyst and there is a good
example where
people have replaced rhodium with iridium
and found that
they can make much more compound in the same
chemical
plant and this is really good because then
you get more stuff
coming out without having to have any more
metal work.
Chemical engineers have a very nice name for
this it is called
de-bottlenecking when you get more for the
same amount of
plant.